the government's advice to stay at home
protect the NHS and save lives but we
are hearing in the last few moments that
the Prime Minister has been taken to
hospital our political editor Beth Rigby
can join us now
Beth we know that the Prime Minister was
still suffering from a temperature he
certainly hasn't looked well has he when
he's made recent public appearances now
we're being told he's going to hospital
yes that's right Jonathan this news
literally has broken in the last couple
of minutes you've read out the statement
there on the advice of the doctor the
Prime Minister has gone to hospital for
tests we saw him didn't we in that video
just last week he didn't look that well
but he's been working he's still carried
on but 10 days after he went into sight
self-isolation with coronavirus he's
still obviously not getting better last
week he still had a temperature after a
week which was why he continued to self
isolate as I understand it he still has
persistent symptoms
he still has a high temperature but
these are purely precautionary reasons
that he's gone to hospital for tests as
I understand it this is not an emergency
admission and the decision was taken on
the advice of his doctor and he remains
in charge of government and he's still
in contact with ministerial colleagues
and officials so the Prime Minister has
been admitted to hospital for tests he
still has a persistent temperature 10
days after being tested positive for
coronavirus but as I understand it this
is not an emergency admission this is a
precautionary admission on the advice
for his doctor from his doctor but the
news here is that Boris Johnson has had
to go to hospital tonight because of
that coronavirus that he came down with
ten days ago